اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى هذه الساعه من
العربيه نكمل فيها تغطيه لاهداعيات
الزلزال الذي ضرب الجارتين تركيا وسوريا
جزاء القرن المشاهدين في تركيا وشمال
سوريا لليوم الثاني على التوالي تستمر
عمليات البحث بين الانقاض وسط التسجيل
حالات انسانيه مؤثره وتعاطف عالمي زلزال
اعقبته سلسله من الهزات الارتداديه حصله
ضحاياه في تزايد المدمر وهزاته ارتداديه
على طول الحدود التركيه السوريه خلاف 9800
قتيل حتى الان في تركيا مشاهدينا ارتفع
عدد ضحايا الزلزال القرن زلزال القرن الذي
دام 60 دقيقه الى اكثر من سبعه الاف ومئه
قتيل والاصابات تلامس الاربعين الف جريح
اثار زلزال المدمر قد تستمر لسنوات وفقا
لخبراء هذا وبدا سريان حاله الطوارئ في
تركيا لمده ثلاثه اشهر في المناطق
المنكوبه في سوريا المجاوره ارتفعت حاصله
الضحايا لاكثر من 2700 قتيل والاصابات
تخطط الخمسه الاف جريح جراء زلزال وتوابعه
فرق الانقاذ مشاهدينا تسابق الزمن
الانتشار الضحايا والعالقين تحت انقاض
الابنيه التي دمرها زلزال تركيا وسوريا
على صعيد الجهود الاغافيه تواصل الحمله
السعوديه استقبال التبرعات لاغاثه
المتضررين من الزلزال في كل من تركيا
وسوريا مشاهدينا حيث تجاوز اجمالي
التبرعات ثلاثه عشر مليون ريال خلال سته
عشره ساعه من اطلاق الحمله العهد السعودي
مشاهدينا الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز وولي
العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان وجهها ايضا
مركز الملك سلمان للاغاثه والاعمال
الانسانيه بتسيير كسر جوي الى تركيا والى
سوريا كذلك
وتقديم مساعدات صحيه وايوائيه وغدائيه
لتخفيف اثار الزلزال
هذه الصور المباشره اذا حيث يواصل عمال
انقاذ عمليات البحث عن ناجينا بين انقاض
الاف المباني التي انهارت بسبب الزلزال
الذي ضرب جنوب تركيا وشمال غرب سوريا صباح
الاثنين والذي بلغت قوته ايضا سبعه درجات
فاصله ثمانيه يشار مشاهدينا الى ان زلزال
الاول
وقع يوم الاثنين على عمق نحو 17 كيلو مترا
فاصله تسعه وفق المعهد الامريكي للمسح
الجيولوجي مركزه كان في منطقته بازارجيك
في محافظه كهرمان بالكهرمان مرعش التركيه
على مسافه 60 كيلومترا من الحدود السوريه
الحصيه الاجماليه مشاهدينا لعدد قلقتله في
البلدين تجاوزت
9,800 قتيل وهو ما نلاحظه الان على شاشه
العربيه هذا الخبر عاجل ارتفاع حصيره
ضحايا زلزال في سوريا وتركيا لاكثر من 9
قتيل وفق حصيله غير نهائيه
ايضا في متابعه هذه الصور المباشره
لعمليات الايقاده التي تجريها فرق البحث
في كل من تركيا وسوريا بحثا عن ناجين بين
الانقاض وبين هذا الركام السلطات التركيه
المشاهدين ايضا ارتفاع عدد الضحايا في
اراضيها الى سبعه الاف ومائه وثمانيه قتلى
الجرحى الى اكثر من اربعه وثلاثين الفا
الجريح
مشاهدينا ينضم الينا من اسطنبول نائب
الرئيس ومسؤول العلاقات الخارجيه بهات
الاغاثه الانسانيه وحقوق الانسان والحريات
امركايا اهلا بك معنا في هذه التغطيه
ووفقا لمتابعتك وكونك في هذا المجال
المتعلق بالانقاذ والاغاثه ما هي ابرز
مشاهداتك وكيف يمكن ان توصف الاوضاع الان
في تركيا
طبعا اولا
الامر
بقسوه الصعوبه طبعا هناك نقطتين مهمتين هو
قوه الزلزال واحاطه المناطق نحن الان
نتحدث في منطقه
اكبر من
كمساحه من بريطانيا
وهناك نحن نتحدث عن 10 مدن
وايضا يحتوي 16 مليون شخص يعيش في هذه
المنطقه
وخاصه
بسبب ايضا ان نكون في موسم الشتاء
الازمه خاصه في في الليالي
يكبر الازمه بكثير جدا
والان الامور حتى الى يومنا هذا متركزه
بعمليه الانقاذ والبحث لان هناك ما زال
تحت الانقاص الناس
ينتظرون
الوصول الايادي اليه
ما هي العقبه التي تواجهنا تحديدا اكبر
مشكله تواجه هيئه الاغاثه في تركيا حاليا
وسط هذه الظروف الصعبه الان
هكذا لازم ان نفهم الموضوع انه هناك
الازمه
كبير جدا يعني
الان المنطقه
التضرر
متوزعه على المدن يعني لا نتحدث عن مدينه
واحده وليس هذه المدن النسمه عددهم صغيره
كبير الاعداد يعني نحن نتحدث عن الان
بارقام الرسميه السيد امرا اعذرني ساقاطع
قليلا لكن ساعود اليك هذه التغطيه
مشاهدينا الان نذهب الى الرياض لمتابعه
الاطلاق الرسمي للحمله السعوديه لاغاثه
المتضررين من زلزال تركيا وسوريا
اذا مشاهدينا نحن بانتظار الاطلاق الرسمي
للحمله السعوديه لاغاثه المتضررين من
زلزال تركيا وسوريا
بدات في هذه اللحظه نتابع الى مشاهدينا
بالصوت الطبيعي
ايها الطيور الكرام
في هذا الصفحه الانساني مركز بني سلمان
للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه الذي انشئ ان
يجسد تعاليمنا من الحديث التي تنجب غابه
الملهم ومساعده المحتاج والمحافظه على
حياه الانسان
وكرامته وصحته
لا بمناسبه
معاني المستشار في الديوان الملكي المشرف
العام على مركز الملك سلمان للغاته
والاعمال الانسانيه الدكتور عبد الله
ربيعه
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
ان فاذا لتوجيهات خادم الحرمين الشريفين
الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز
وسمو ولي عهده الامين صاحب السمو الملكي
الامير محمد بن سلمان بن عبد العزيز
رئيس مجلس الوزراء حفظهم الله ندشن اليوم
حمله التبرعات الشعبيه
لمتضرري الزلزال بسوريا وتركيا وتوجيه
الكريم الذي جاء ليجسد
المعالم
والصفات النبيله التي تتحلى بها قياده هذا
الوطن المعطاء
وشعبه الكريم
ليقوم مركز الملك سلمان
بمشاركه جهات ووزارات سعوديه مهمه
لدعم كل من تضرر واصيب من الاشقاء في
سوريا وتركيا
سوف تكون هذه الحمله حمله شعبيه لجمع
التبرعات سواء من كانت من خلال تطبيق ساهم
او من خلال الحساب البنكي الموحد المخصص
لهذه الحمله او من خلال قنوات التبرعات
المتعدده التي موجوده على موقع مركز الملك
سلمان للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه
ولله الحمد قبل ان تطلق هذه الحمله
تعدت التبرعات اكثر من 13 مليون ريال
سعودي وهذا يجسد الصفات النبيله للشعب
السعودي الوفي الكريم الذي استجاب لدعوه
خادم الحرمين الشريفين وولي عهده الامين و
نؤكد للمتبرعين ان موقع ساهم اذا
المتبرعين متبرعين بعض التحديات بسبب حجم
التبرعات ان هنالك قنوات اخرى ممثله في
الرقم الحسابي الموحد الذي يمكن التبرع
منه او من خلال القنوات الاخرى الموجوده
على موقع المركز كما اؤكد ان هذه الحمله
سوف
تشكل برامج متعدده سوف يستفاد من هذه
المبالغ من برامج متعدده وجه بها المقام
الكريم لخادم الحرمين الشريفين وولي عهد
الامين سوف يدشن جسر جوي خلال الساعات
القادمه باذن الله لحمل التبرعات سواء
كانت ايوائيه او صحيه او غذائيه كما سوف
تقوم فرق الانقاذ
بالسفر الى مواقع الحدث
لانقاذ المصابين والمتضررين من هذا
الزلزال وسوف تكون هنالك فرق تدخل سريع
وفرق طوارئ طبيه ذات تدخل سريع وكذلك فرق
تطوعيه من الكوادر السعوديه التي تبرعت
بوقتها وجهدها وخبرتها لتخفيف المصاب
الجلل الذي اصاب الاشقاء في سوريا وتركيا
كما اننا سوف نحمل ما نستطيع من مواد
ايوائيه وكذلك غذائيه وصحيه وفقا لما تقوم
به فرق التقييم التي وجه بها خادم الحرمين
الشريفين لتقييم الاحتياج الانساني الذي
يستطيع منها فريق مركز الملك سلمان والفرق
الاخرى لدعم هذه التدخل
نحن في هذا المقام لا يسعنا الا ان نرفع
اسمى ايات الشكر والتقدير والعرفان لمقام
خادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز وولي عهده الامين صاحب السمو
الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان بن عبد
العزيز حفظهما الله على هذه المبادره
الانسانيه النبيله والسريعه كذلك لا يسعني
الا ان اشكر الفرق المشاركه التي سوف
تشارك في هذا العمل السعودي النبيل واخص
منها الفرق الميدانيه سواء كانت من
المديريه العامه للدفاع المدني بوزاره
الداخليه او هيئه الهلال الاحمر السعودي
او الكوادر المتميزه من مركز الملك سلمان
للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه او كذلك
المتطوعون والمتطوعات الذين
بادروا بالتسجيل لدى المركز لتقديم
الخدمات الطبيه والصحيه العاجله في
الميدان كذلك اشكر الوزارات والجهات
الداعمه ممثله
بوزارات الدفاع والداخليه والاعلام
والماليه والجهات المختصه الاخرى اسال
الله سبحانه وتعالى ان يوفقنا وان يساعدنا
لتنفيذ التوجيهات الكريمه وان نكون
لدينا القدره والاستطاعه ان نخفف مصاب
اخواننا واخواتنا في كل من سوريا وتركيا
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
شكرا جزيلا لكم
اذا مشاهدينا كنا معكم في متابعه لهذه
الكلمه التي القاها الدكتور عبد الله
الربيع المشرفه العام على مركز الملك
سلمان الاغاثه والذي اعلن من خلالها اطلاق
الحمل السعوديه لاغاثه المتضررين في سوريا
وتركيا مركز الملك سلمان على لسان دكتور
عبد الله ربيع قال نشاركه مع جهات سعوديه
لاغاثه المتضررين من الزلازل وتحدث عن انه
قبل اطلاق الحمله تجاوزت التبرعات اكثر من
13 مليون ريال سعودي وستكون هناك فرق تدخل
سريع وفرق طوارئ طبيه
وسندشن جسرا جويا خلال ساعات لاغاثه سوريا
وتركيا مشاهدينا في متابعه هذه الصور
المباشره ايضا من منطقه تغازي عنتاب في
تركيا لعمليات الانقاذ التي يجرها عمال
انقاذ بحثا عن ناجين بين انقاض المباني
التي انهارت بسبب هذا الزلزال الذي ضرب
جنوب تركيا وشمال غرب سوريا
يوم الاثنين والذي بلغت قوته سبعه درجات
فاصله ثمانيه على مقياس ريختر نذكر
مشاهدينا بان السلطات التركيه قد اعلنت ان
عدد الضحايا وصل في اراضيها الى سبعه
الاف180 قتيل وعدد الجرحى تجاوز اربعه
وثلاثين الف جريح فرقه الاغاثه التركيه
مشاهدينا ايضا كانت احصت يوم امس انهيار
خمسه الاف بل اكثر من 5600 مبنى في العديد
من المدن اما
سوريا ايضا فقد تجاوز فيها الاعداد هناك
يعني زياده مضطره طبعا في العادات المصل
السوري يقول ان سقط
نحو71 قتيلا في حصيله طبعا مرشحه للارتفاع
بسبب صعوبه الوصول الى كثير من العالقين
تحت الانقاض مشاهدينا الان من اضنه
التركيه ينضم الينا زيدان العربي اهلا بك
زي واخر التفاصيل لديك حول عمليات البحث
عن ناجين زيدان في المناطق التركيه
نعم انا سابدا من اضنه من هذا المكان الذي
اتواجد فيه ولن اطيل الكلام كثيرا امام
الكاميرا سادع زميلي المصور ياخذ هذه
اللقطات الان لعمليه انقاذ مستمره منذ
لحظه حدوث الزلزال حتى هذه اللحظه يبدو
عفوا
يبدو ان الفرق الانقاذ قد عثرت على شيء ما
لا نستطيع الاقتراب اكثر الشرطه كانت
منعتنا من الاقتراب بعد ما كنا في النشرات
الماضيه قريبين من مواقع الانقاذ الان تم
استدعاء سيارات الاسعاف لا ندري هل هناك
ناجم او شخص ما زال على قيد الحياه
الجهود تكثفت في هذه النقطه التي تصورها
كاميرا العربيه مباشره هذه النقطه قبل
ساعتين تقريبا كان فريق خبير احضر بعض
الاجهزه المتطوره وكلاب مدربه قاموا الفحص
المكان وحددوا هذه النقطه طبعا
حفر تشتبه السلطات بان او فرق الانقاذ هنا
بان هناك اشخاص ما زالوا عالقين تحت هذا
البناء احد
المسؤولين عن عمليه الانقاذ او احد
مسؤولين هنا ابلغنا ان الاجهزه الاستشعار
حددت وجود اشخاص على عمق يتراوح بين اثنين
فاصله اربعه الى اثنين فاصله ثمانيه تحت
هذا الركام لذلك تم مضاعفه اعداد المنقذين
هنا او طواقم الانقاذ وايضا جلبوا فريق
اخر من الخبراء واجهزه اخرى متطوره للبحث
هنا
هل تسمع اصوات للناجين او العالقين
نعم يوم امس مساء امس كان هناك سماع
لاصوات اشخاص لكن حتى هذا اليوم لم يكن
هناك سماعات تم طلبه فرق الانقاذ مرارا من
الاشخاص او كل من يوجد في هذا المكان سواء
كان الشرطه او مسعفين او حتى مواطنين رغم
ان المواطنين بعيدين نوعا ما عن عمليات
الانقاذ او موقع الانقاذ لكن طلبوا من
الجنه حتى الاليات وساده كما يجري بالصوت
الطبيعي زيدان دعنا نستمع معك الى هذه
الاصوات
سنحاول الان بث الصوت الطبيعي
وصل الى
طيب زيدان بمجرد سماع اصوات ناجين تحت
الارقام يعني ما هي الخطوه التاليه كيف
يتم الوصول اليهم او محاولهم بامان من قبل
العمال الانقاذ
نعم نعم هذا الموضوع
[موسيقى]
زيدان هل تسمعني تمام تمام هذا الموضوع
يتطلب نعم اسمعك احمد بكل وضوح نعم اتحدث
الان عندما يتم سماع اصوات يتم توجيه فرق
الانقاذ لنحو المكان الذي خرجت منه اصوات
ومن ثم يتم استخدام الفريق المتخصص بتحديد
الموقع والاجهزه التي يمكن ان تعطي بدقه
هذا الموضوع الان الان الان طلبوا الصمت
من الجميع واطفاء الاليه
ايضا نحاول ان نتكلم بصوت منخفض
صمت يسود نعم نعم نعم
صمت يسود الموقع محاوله لسماع اشخاص او
الان الشرطه تطلب من الجميع التوقف
الصمت وترقب في هذا المكان لحظات عصيبه
حقيقه
[موسيقى]
الان يطلبون الصمت مجددا
على ما يبدو سيطلبون سنتابع هل سيتم اخلاء
الموقع امس ستستمر عمليات الحفر نتابع
معكم مباشره هذه اللحظات حقيقه الصعبه على
شاشه قناه العربيه
كما تتابعون الان تتواصل عمليات الحفر
يبدو ان هناك نقطه معينه يريدون الوصول
الحفر اكثر في هذه النقطه لكن الحفر
باليات بسيطه فقط منعا للانجراف
التربه او انجراف الركام الى او نزول
الركام على الاشخاص الذين تعتقد او يعتقد
فريق الانقاذ انهم عالقون تحت الانقاض احد
الاشخاص الذين
قابلناهم قبل قليل اخبرنا انه يعرف عائله
كانت تقيم هنا في الطابق السابع وان ثلاثه
او من هذه العائله خمسه اشخاص ما زالوا
تحت الانقاض ثلاثه نساء ورجال اثنين طبعا
هذا الشخص اخبرنا ايضا ان ابن اخي او ابن
شقيقه ابن اخيه توفي هذا اليوم واخرجوا او
اخرجوا جثته هذا اليوم من هذا البناء من
تحت الانقاض لذلك كما ذكرت يعني الكل هنا
يتابع بترقب وخوف ويعني امل ودعاء ودعاء
عفوا بان يكون هناك ناجين وان تتواصل
العمليات حتى الوصول الى كل العالقين تحت
هذا المبنى الذي كان مكونا من 14 طابقا
يعني احمد حقيقه يعني توقيت الزلزال عندما
وقع في الرابعه
وسبعه عشر دقيقه بالتوقيت المحلي الجميع
كان نيام لذلك المتوقع ان يكون هناك اعداد
كبيره تحت الانقاض هنا وبالتالي عندما
عثرت او عثر فريق الانقاذ على بصيص امل
بوجود اشخاص طلب من الدعم من السلطات هنا
في اضنه وبالفعل وصلت وصلت تقريبا تضاعفت
اعداد فرق الانقاذ وحتى فرق الخبراء
الاجنبيه ايضا وصل اكثر فريق شاهدناه هنا
سواء فرق احضرت كلاب مدربه او فرق ايضا
احضرت اجهزه حديثه للمشاركه في هذه
العمليه وبناء على توجيه هذه الفرق
والنقاط التي حددوها يتم الحفر بتاني
ورويش وهدوء شديد حتى لا يؤدي هذا الحفر
الى اي ضرر على الاشخاص الذين هم يتواجدون
تحت هذه الانقاض وهذا الركام كما نشاهد
على العمليات مستمره طبعا العمليات هنا
كما ذكرت يعني عمليه صعبه ومعقده لا سيما
ان المباني المجاوره احمد اذا استطاع
زميلي ان يلتقط لنا بعد المباني سنحاول
سنحاول الان الكاميرا التي تتحرك تجاه هذا
المبنى الابيض على يسار الشاشه فيه بعض
التشققات او تشققات ليست بالقليله يعني
مبنى مكون من 14 طابقا في تشققات وصلت الى
الطابق الثالث هناك خشيه لدى فرق الانقاذ
من ان اي قويه ربما قد تؤدي الى انهيارات
في هذا المبنى لذلك هذا اليوم صباح هذا
اليوم كنا قريبين ونصور في النشاط السابق
قرب هذا المبنى لكن الان ممنوع لاي شخص
سوى الفرق العامله في هذا الموقع
هذه المعدات زيدان ايضا يمكن ان تتسبب في
انهيار هذا المبنى ليس كذلك هناك مخاطر
ايضا من استخدام هذه المعدات الثقيله في
هذا الموقع صحيح بالضبط
امام امرين احلاهما مر اما ان يواصل العمل
بهذه الاليات الضروريه واللازمه لعمليه
الانقاذ ولا يمكن ان
تتم هذه العمليه بدون استخدام هذه الاليات
او ابقاء هذه الاليات بعيدا حرصا على عدم
انهيارات اخرى في هذه المباني المجاوره
لكن يتم العمل بهذه الاليات برفق نوعا ما
بتانن بعدم
اذا
هذه هذه الصوره يسال اصحاب
هذا المسعف يحاول ابراز صوره وجدوها في
الموقع لطفله الان اخفى هذه الصوره
يحاولون اذا تعرف على هذه الاشخاص على هذه
الصوره يبدو ان احد الاشخاص يختلف نعم نعم
يسالون هل هناك
محاولات الان نحاول الاقتراب هل تسمح لنا
الشرطه ام لا
هناك بعض المواطنين الذين يريدون رؤيه
الصوره بالفعل
ذهبوا الى هناك
الشرطه تبعد البقيه كما نشاهد الشرطه تبعد
البقيه فقط من يستطيع التعرف على هذه
الصوره وهناك الكثير من الاحاديث في هذا
الموقع
السكان هذا المبنى تم اخلائها من خرج حيا
طبعا تم اخلاقه الى مراكز ايواء مؤقته
قريبه من هذا المكان والمباني الفارغه
التي صورناها قبل قليل ايضا تم اخلاقهم
لكن اقارب بعض الاشخاص او اقارب الاشخاص
الذين يعتقد انهم ما زالوا تحت الانقاض
هنا لكن الشرطه تمنع الجميع من الاقتراب
يعني حتى لا يؤثر هذا
التجمع او التجمهور على عمل رجال
الانقاذين حتى يمنعونهم حتى من الاقتراب
من كاميرات الصحافه هم بعيدون نوعا ما عن
خلف الكادر لكن بين الفينه والاخرى هناك
اشخاص يعني لا يستطيعون الانتظار ويحاولون
الاقتراب من الموقع لكن الشرطه تبعدهم
يعني حفاظا على حياتهم طبعا يعني الموضوع
يؤثر على عمل رجال الانقاذ هناك ايضا مخاط
مخاطر او مخاوف من انهيارات ربما تحصل في
المنطقه سواء من اهتزازات الاليات الثقيله
او
ان يقرب الصوره اكثر على فرق الانقاذ واود
ايضا ان اسالك عن هذه الفرق يعني مما
تتكون انه نلاحظ ان هناك عناصر من الشرطه
هناك عناصر من الدفاع المدني هل كلهم
اتراك هل هناك تواجد لفرق اجنبيه التي
وصلت وبدات منذ امس عملها في الاراضي
التركيه
نعم عندما وصلنا الى هذا الموقع مساء امس
تقريبا وصلنا الى هنا في تمام الساعه
الثامنه بالتوقيت المحلي تقريبا كل
الكوادر التي كانت موجوده هم من كوادر
محليه من الاتراك لكن حتى الاليات التي
نشاهدها الان الاليات الثقيله لم تقم بهذا
العدد وهذا الكم لكن عندما كان هناك بصيص
امل بوجود اشخاص على قيد الحياه وكما
تحدثنا قبل قليل سمعوا مرتين مساء امس
اصوات من تحت الانقاض واشتعل هذا المكان
الذي نتواجد فيه فرحا بوجود اشخاص ناجين
تم طلب تعزيزات انا اتحدث عن اعداد ضعف
الاعداد التي كانت متواجده امس من ناحيه
عدد الاشخاص او حتى عدد الاليات طبعا من
بين
المعدات الموجوده من ضمن المعدات الموجوده
ايضا عفوا من ضمن الكوادر الموجوده هناك
خبراء اجانب وفرق انقاذ اجنبيه قدموا الى
هنا للمشاركه والمساعده طبعا كما تحدثت
قبل قليل احضروا معهم كلاب مدربه واجهزه
استشعار هذه الاجهزه هي التي كشفت وهذه
الكلاب هي التي حددت ايضا الموقع الذي
ترصدها الكاميرا الان وطلب الخبراء من
الجميع الحفر هنا لكن بادوات بسيطه دون
استخدام اليات ثقيله الاليات والرافعات
الثقيله فقط هي تقوم برفع الكتل الخرسانيه
الضخمه يعني الجميع يعمل هنا وفق اشراف
الفريق المختص
كما نتابع الان بعض المواطنين يتقدمون
باتجاه هذا الموقع لكن الان الشرطه ايضا
تبعدهم عن هذا المكان بالفعل يعني هذا
المكان حسب ما علمنا يوم اليوم الاول من
الزلزال وصباح يوم امس حتى صباح امس
اخرجوا منه خمس اشخاص على قيد الحياه
وصباح هذا اليوم لدى وصولنا شاهدنا اخراج
عدد من الجثث من الاشخاص مع الاسف فارق
الحياه ولم تتمكن الفرق على الانقاذ من
الوصول اليهم في الوقت المناسب
ايضا ما زالت كما تحدث كل هذه الجهود بعد
الاشارات التي
اتتاكيدات من قبل فريق الخبراء بان هناك
اشخاص تحت هذه الانقراض هذه المنطقه التي
نشاهدها على شاشه العربيه سويه هي التي
حددها الخبراء للحفر وطلبوا من الفريق او
المتطوعين هنا اتمام عمليه الحفر كل شيء
يتم وفق قواعد يحددها فريق الخبراء هم من
يحددون كميه الحفر المطلوبه والاليات
المستخدمه والادوات المستخدمه ويطلبون
الاليات الثقيله الحفر في مناطق معينه او
الابتعاد عن المناطق معينه هذا الموضوع
بصراحه معقد ويشهد بحاجه الى صبر وتاني
شديدين ودقه شديده حتى لا يكون او لا
تنقلب هذه الامور
لا تنقلب هذه الامور بشكل سلبي الان هناك
اغطيه احضرت هل عثر على جثث سنحاول الان
معرفه ذلك
نتمنى ان يكون هناك ناجين وان لا تخرج جثث
جديده نتمنى العثور على احياء يعني حقيقه
بعد كل هذا الصبر
نعم بالضبط احمد بعد كل هذا الصبر وهذه
الجهود نتمنى ان تتكلم هذه الجهود بنتائج
ايجابيه طبعا يعني حتى موضوع اخراج الجثث
هو شيء لا مفر منه لكن يعني نامل ان يكون
هناك نتائج ايجابيه والعثور على ناجين
نتابع هذه اللحظات
هل سيكون هناك اخراج للجثث ام لاشخاص
في هذه اللحظات زيدان
نعم نعم نعم طعم نعم بالضبط الكل على
اعصابه هنا يعني الكاميرا لا تستطيع ان
ترصد كل المكان طبعا المكان الذي نتواجد
فيه مجبرين حقيقه على ان نتواجد على هذه
المسافه بطلب من الشرطه التي ابعدتنا في
اكثر من مناسبه عن هذا الموقع وحددت لنا
هذا المكان للوقوف والتصوير نحاول الان ان
نرصد
هذه اللقطات الان يعني وضع هذه الاغذيه
بهذا الشكل زيدان لماذا عاده يعني لماذا
لماذا يتم
استخدامها بهذه الطريقه يعني ما الذي يشير
اليه ذلك
يعني الان لا اريد ان اعطي مؤشرات سلبيه
لكن عندما استخدموا هذه الاغطيه صباحا
اخرجوا جثث
لعدم
حتى لا الاقارب او المواطنين الذين كانوا
يتواجدون هنا حتى لا يتمكنوا من مشاهده
المنظر لكن لا اريد ان استبرق الاحداث
الان ومع الاسف الان اليات جديده وقفت
امام الكاميرا سنحاول تغيير مكان الكاميرا
بسرعه او الان الشرطه تطلب من هذه الاليات
الرحيل والابتعاد عن المكان هذه اليات
ايضا في هذا الموقع تساعد في عمليه
الانقاذ ونقل الركام الان تبدا لهذه
الاليات لا اريد ان استبق الاحداث سنحاول
ان نبقى متفائلين وبظهور احياء من هذا
المبنى قبل ان نتحدث في السيناريو الاخر
نتابع معكم على الهواء مباشره هذه العمليه
طيب مشاهدين ان نتابع معكم هذه الصور من
اضنه في تركيا وكما قال مراسل العربيه قبل
قليل هناك السماع لاصوات ناجي تحت الانقاض
في اضنه بتركيا هناك فرق الانقاذ مكونه من
الشرطه ومن فرق اجنبيه وفرق تركيه ايضا
تحاول جاهده البحث
وسماء اصوات حتى هذا الركام
لاخراج ناجين او عالقين في هذه المنطقه
هناك بعض الاهالي يتجمعون حول هذه البنايه
التي تم اقناؤها قبل سقوطها بعضهم نجا
بعضهم ما زال تحت هذه الانقاض جهود كبيره
وحثيثه والدقيقه جدا تقوم بها هذه السلطات
ويقوم بها خبراء ايضا لاخراج العالقين تحت
هذه الانقاض هناك بعض من اقضوا بعد هذه
الابقار وهناك من تم تم اخراجه على قيد
الحياه كما قالوا زيدان قبل قليل نحن ما
في متابعه هذه اللقطات ما الذي يحدث الان
يمكن ان تصف لنا ما تشاهده
على ما اعتقد انهم وصلوا الى احد الاشخاص
العالقين سنتاكد هل هو على قيد الحياه ام
قد فارق الحياه
حقيقه اللحظات عصيبه لحظات قد تكتب فيها
الحياه لشخص وقد يفارق
بعض الاشخاص حبيب او قريب لهم ننتظر في
لحظات
الرجال الانقاذ يحاولون ابعاد البعض
الاشخاص الذين اقتربوا لمشاهده ما يجري
نامل ان لا تكون جثه جديده نامل ان نحظى
او يحظى بعض الاشخاص المنتظرين هنا بفرحه
بولايه عمر او كتابه حياه جديده لشخص كان
تحت الانقاب منذ يومين ونصف اليوم تقريبا
يعني نحن دخلنا اليوم الثالث ومنذ تقريبا
عده ساعات
الان نتابع معكم
الان الطواقم الطبيه وصلت الى المكان
احاول
المشاهده كمسافه نوعا ما بعيده ساحاول
الاقتراب اكثر
تمام لو انا عند اخر نقطه الان الشرطه
حاولنا الاقتراب لكن الشرطه الان طلبت
الابتعاد هناك
نعم نعم هناك شخص ناجن الان العثور على
شخص على قيد الحياه في هذه اللحظات وهناك
تكبير في الموقع من قبل الفرق الانقاذ على
ما يبدو ان هناك شخص على قيد الحياه قد
وصلوا اليه احمد ان كنت تسمعني
الحمد لله
احد رجال الشرطه كان يخبرني انا معكم عن
الهواء اننا شخص على قيد الحياه محاول
الان حقيقه لحظات عصيبه لا يمكن وصف
المشهد احمد هنا من حولي لا نستطيع ان
نزيح الكاميرا عن هذا المشهد لكن
المترقب وخوف والكل يعمل بان يكون له قريب
هو او الكل يعمل ان كان له احد الاشخاص
موجودين هنا ان يكون هذا هو الناجي هو احد
الاقرباء او الاحباء الذي
ينتظره لحظات عصيبه حقيقه احمد نتمنى ان
تكون هذه التكبيرات فعلا هي لشخص خرج على
قيد الحياه سننتظر حتى الان ووضعوا
الاغطيه بشكل كامل حتى لا يستطيع احد رؤيه
هذا الموضوع وعمليات الاجلاء هذا المبنى
تحديدا هل عثر فيه على احياء خلال الساعات
الماضيه
نعم كما قلت لكم خلال الايام الماضيه نعم
هناك احياء تم اخراجهم من هذا المبنى مره
اخرى اليه تدخل المكان الشرطه ستخرجها
فورا لعدم عرقله اي جهود لعمليه الانقاذ
نعم رغم ان هذه الاليات تشارك في عمليات
الانقاذ لكن الان الوضع حساس يتم ابعاد كل
الاليات تم ابعاد الاليه والصوره مجددا
معكم
نتمنى ان نصل الى نتيجه ايجابيه قريبا نعم
احمد كنت سالتني ان كان هناك خروج احياء
نعم اخرجوا عدد من الاشخاص احد المسعفين
قال لانهم اخرجوا حتى صباح الامس خمسه
اشخاص وكانت الجهود ما زالت مستمره للبحث
عن اشخاص اخرين ما زلنا نحاول ان نرصد هنا
هذا المشهد
اليات جديده تصل الى الموقع هذه الفرق
الان المتركزه في هذه المنطقه هل توازيها
فرق اخرى في مناطق اخرى في اضنه ام ان كل
الفرق تتجمع في مكان واحد وبعد ان تنتهي
من مبنى معين تتحول الى مبنى اخر ما هي
الاليه لعمليه الانقاذ في هذه المنطقه
كل الاماكن التي فيها دمار فيها فرق انقاذ
لكن هذا الموقع تكثفت فيه الجهود اكثر من
غيره عندما علموا بوجود اشخاص او احتمال
وجود اشخاصهم على قيد الحياه
جلب تعزيزات جريده وهذا هو السيناريو
عندما يكون في كل المواقع هناك اشخاص تعمل
فرق انقاذ تعمل عندما يكون هناك شك او
اشتباه بوجود اشخاص على قيد الحياه
فورا ياتي او يطلبون دعم ومن ثم ياتي
الدعم الان الان هناك صمت يطلبون الصمت
يطلبون الصمت واطفاء الاليات لا نعلم ما
يجري الان
صمت يسود الموقع بشكل كامل
يريدون سماع شيء
لحظات عصيبه حقيقه على الجميع هنا
مجددا يطلبون الجميع الصمت
مجددا يطلبون
هناك سياره اسعاف قادمه وسيارات اسعاف
وصلت الى الموقع نتمنى فعلا ان تكون هناك
ان يكون هناك ناجين لكن سيات الاسعاف ايضا
توقفت بناء على طلب الشرطه وطلب اطفاء هذه
السيارات
صمت كامل يلوحون حتى لاشخاص موجودين هنا
للصمت واطفاء حتى الهواتف
لحظات عصيبه تخطف الامثال الجميع يترقب
الجميع
يقول ادعيه الجميع يقرا ايات من القران
املا في ان تكون هناك ناجي
طيب ازيد نحن الان في متابعه معك لهذه
اللحظات العصيبه في اضنه التركيه وفرق
الانقاذ تحاول انقاذ اشخاص من تحت انقاض
هذا المبنى بعد يومين من الزلزال نذكر
مشاهدينا ان فرق الاغاثه التركيه كانت
احصت انهيار اكثر من 5600 مبنى في العديد
من المدن هذا المبنى هو احد الان طلبوا من
سيارات الاسعاف التقدم احمد نعم
نعم اتفضل الان سيارات الاسعاف تتقدم طلب
من احدثات اسعافه نعم احدث سلاسل اسعاف
تتقدم هل ستاتي
السيارات الاسعاف الان
وصلت الى الموقع هناك
سياره اسعاف وصلت الى المكان
الان حتى السيارات الاسعاف يطلبون منها
الابتعاد عن الموقع حتى لا تظهر اي صوت
حتى يطلب من سياده الاسعاف الشرطه هنا
الشرطه امامنا تطلب رساله الاسعاف حتى
الابتعاد عن هذا المكان على ما يبدو ان
وجود سيارات الاسعاف هنا هو اجراء احترازي
لكن حتى الاجراء الاحترازي يجب ان يكون
بعيدا نوعا ما عن مكان او موقع عمليات
الانقاذ
[موسيقى]
تواجد سيارات الاسعاف زيدان هل يعني
بالضروره ان من عثروا عليهم على قيد
الحياه ام ان حتى الجثث يتم تحميلها على
سياره الاسعاف
صباح هذا اليوم تم تحميل الجثث بسيارات
نقل الموتى عندما تم اخراجهم لذلك الان
الجميع هون هنا متفائل بوجود
ناجين لا نعلم او حتى ان كانوا مصابين
ربما يتم اسعافهم او تلقيهم العلاج بشكل
سريع عبر ساعات الاسعاف لذلك نترقب معكم
سنه اسعاف الان وقفت على مقربه من هذا
الموقع ابتعدت قليلا لكن وقفت على مقربه
ننتظر حاله ترقب كل الجهود التي كانت
الجهود المضنيه خلال الساعات الماضيه الان
ستتكشف نتيجه هذه الجهود او ان شاء الله
تكون النتيجه ايجابيه كما ذكرنا او قبل
قليل سمعنا من الموقع تكبير يعني ان هناك
شخص ما زال على قيد الحياه هذا هذه هذا ما
جرت العاده عليه خلال الساعات الماضيه
عندما تاتي اصواتنا الداخل الجميع يكبر
ويهلل ويكون سعيد
بهذه النتيجه بان شخص ما زال على قيد
الحياه وتحاول الفرق الوصول اليه كما
نلاحظ يعني لا يوجد اعمال حفر ربما هناك
اشخاص يحاولون سحب شيء ما لا نستطيع الان
الوصول
اذا نظرنا الى هذا السائق في هذه العربه
يدعي ويقرا الفاتحه
يعني لا يمكن وصف المشهد حقيقه الكاميرا
لا يمكن ان تنقل الصوره كامله احمد يعني
الكل هنا في حاله ترقب وخوف وقلق على
الطرف الاخر المواطنين الذين تجمعوا في
الشارع رغم كل محاولات رجال الشرطه
ابعادهم ابعادهم عن هذه المنطقه نعم هم
بعيدون نوعا ما لكن يمكن مشاهدتهم من هنا
حقيقه لا يمكن لا يمكن وصف المنظر هنا
يعني الصوره ابلغ من الكلام لكن حتى
الصوره لا تعطي كل
المشهد الذي يدور من حولنا
الان ايضا صمت جديد في هذه المنطقه يطلبون
الصمت مجددا
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدين معكم في متابعه هذه الصور
لحظه الصمت الان في هذا الموقع في منطقه
اضنه في تركيا في محاوله لسماع اصوات
لعالقين تحت الانقاض وذلك بعد يومين من
الزلازل هناك او من الزلزال هناك ايضا
حديث عن ان نفرق الانقاذ تضم ما توصلت الى
شخص في هذه المنطقه وربما يكون الحياه حتى
الان لكنه معكم في متابعه لهذه الصور
المباشره ما يفاقم ايضا مشاهدي
السيارات الابتعاد ايضا تفضل
نعم كنت اتحدث انهم طلبوا حتى من السيارات
الابتعاد
لا ادري هناك احد المسؤولين ربما في ولايه
اضنه وصل
للاشراف او تفقد هذا الموضوع
على ما اعتقد رئيس
نعم هذا هو رئيس بلديه اضنه الذي وصل الان
الى هذا الموقع ايضا
للاشراف على هذه العمليه كما نشاهد
سيدخل الى الموقع في الداخل يحاول
التواصل مع المواطنين الذين تجمعوا هنا
كما نتابع
طيب زيدان ابقى معنا ساعود اليك من جديد
في سياقه هذه الساعه الاخباريه يدخل الى
الموقع ايضا المشاركه
نحن سنقول سنبقى في نقل لهذه الصوره من
عندك زيدان ونعود اليك مره اخرى في سياق
هذه الساعه الاخباريه الامر
الهندي مرحبا بك عمار واخر المعلومات
والمعطيات المتوفره حيث انت الان عمار
ما في داعي بس تقول له خلف هذا احمد نعم
نسمعوك عمار تفضل
اهلا بك نعم نحن لا زلنا في هاتاي طبعا
الدمار هائل يعني كنت استمع لزميل زيدان
واتمنى طبعا خروج كل من هم تحت الانقاض
يعني احياء وعلى قيد الحياه نحن انتقلنا
الى مبنى اخر هنالك في الحقيقه يعني
عائلات باكملها تحت هذه الالقاب كنت تحدثت
الى بعضهم وكنت برايت بام عيني في مبنى
هنا مجاور ساق لسيده من تحت الانقاض
متوفيه للاسف ولكن الرجل ينتظر فرق
الانقاذ ان تنتشر جثمانها وجثمان ابنه
وحفيدته التي يعني كان يوم الزلزال يصادف
يوم ميلادها وللاسف يعني انها رحلت
وسانتقل في الكاميرا وبعد ذلك ساتحدث اولا
للاخ تعرفني عليك
زينب زينب شكله اهلا وسهلا من لك انت الان
تحت الانقاض في اخوي في ملت اخوي في ابن
اخوي تحت الان لا زالوا
عم يفتح التلفون يسكر للشبكه ما في تحت
الارض في تحت الارض يعني انت تتصل على
رقمهم ماذا نجيب على الرقم ما يجي على
الرقم
بس عما يشكل ليش تحت ما في شبكه
ويسكر
ويرضم ما في في احد عم يجي يشتغل عم يقول
له بدنا
لسه الاعمال ما بدات في المبنى اللي هم
فيها
اكيد اكيد احنا يعني انت متامل انهم على
قيد الحياه نعم نحن هن بالحياه اكيد
بالحياه ليش
ما يطلع التلفون ما يطلع ما يشكل ما
يطلعوا ما يشكل تلفوني مندور عليه ما يشكل
تلفوني ما يرن التلفون وما يسكر بس اكيد
اشتغلوا شوي وقالوا بدنا كبشة بدنا
اخوي
تحتذر منك ولضيفك الانتقال الى متابعه
كلمه الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان من
موقع يتفقد فيه احوال
مركز هذا الزلزال كان
كهرمان مرش كهرمان مرشده
لحظات الاولى
وانتشر بموجاته في العشر ولايات الاخرى مع
هزته
عدد الوفيات الان ثمان الاف 800
واربعه وسبعين
وعدد المباني المنهاره هو
افاده اكثر من
6400 مبنى
طبعا من المهم ان ننوه الى نقطه مهمه هنا
صبرني هناك صبر
واعتقد ان الشعب الان والمواطنين سيظهرون
هذا ايضا باستمرار
هنا في كل
المدن المتضرره من هذا الزلزال افادت
تتراس عمليه التنسيق هو الانقاذ والبحث مع
البلديه ومع القوات الاخرى والفرق الاخرى
في كل مدينه
[موسيقى]
يتابع كل المجريات
وفي اليوم الاول طبعا بعض المشاكل في
الوصول الى المناطق المكتوبه والى
المباني ولكن الان استطعنا ان نسيطر
بحجم كانوا بنسبه ممكنه الى هذه
المدن وصدوده لهذه المدن وايضا المباني
ولكن الان نعمل
على عمليه رفع الانقاذ كلها واعاده اعمار
المنطقه في اسرع وقتا ممكن
وسنضع طبعا الحد
لهذا
الموجود وسنحقق الاعمار في سنه كهرمان
التي حصلت في
الاشهر وسنوات الماضيه في عدد مختلف من
المدن
لن نترك اي مواطن في الشارع
سنساعد الجميع وسنقدم المساعدات للجميع
علينا ان ننوه ايضا
انطاليا اولانيا
في انطاليا
طبعا هناك فنادق في انطاليا
ونستمر بالحديث وايهما التواصل واياهم
ونحن سنوجه المواطنين ايضا الى هناك
المتضررين من الزلازل الى سنرسلهم الى
هناك
وسنؤمن لهم الاقامه في هذه الفنادق في
الانيا وانتاليا
وصلنا الى عدد غرف لا باس به يمكن
للمتضررين ان يقيموا هناك طبعا من الممكن
ان يكون المتضررين من الزلزال سعيدين هنا
نحن نعلم ان المخيمات ظروفها صعبه واذا
وافقوا على التوجه الى هذه المدن فنحن
سنساعدهم بالذهاب الى هذه المدن والاقامه
هناك وسناؤهل لهم كل الامكانيات لكي يقيم
هناك بشكل مؤقت الى ان يتم اعمار هذه
المناطق وطبعا سيتم تحديد
المنسقين في هذا الاطار
[موسيقى]
ليحمل اللي ينقلوا عفوا
المنتظرين من هذه الزلازل بنقلهم الى
المدن الاخرى
ولتامين اقامتهم هناك في حال طبعا النقل
المواطنين من هنا الى تلك المدن فنسهل
ايضا عمليه
الانقاذ والبحث هنا اكثر في البدايه كان
هناك مشاكل في الطرق في المطارات ولكن
الان نحن حققنا
تامين هذه الطرق وتامين المطارات هناك بعض
المشاكل ايضا في تامين بعض
المحروقات مثلا او المواد الاخرى ولكن
نتغلب عليها شيئا فشيء ايضا
يساعدوننا في تقديم المحروقات وانابيب
الغاز ايضا الى هذه المدن من اجل تامين
الطهي والدفء وايضا الاحتياجات الاخرى
لذلك
من المهم الان العمل على
تامين العيش بشكل
كريم هنا ونحن طبعا سنؤمن كل الاحتياجات
هنا ولكن من الافضل اذا استطعنا ان ننقل
المصابين او المتضررين من
الزلزال بدلا ان يقيم في هذه المخيمات
بامكانهم ان يقيموا فيه الفنادق في المدن
المختلفه ونحن سنؤمن كل اجور ذلك ايضا من
المهم جدا عدم السماح
للتصريحات
الاستفزازيه والاخبار المستفزه وايضا
الاخبار الكاذبه التي تنتشر على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي من المهم الان ان نركز
على عمليات البحث والانقاذ والتضامن في
هذا الاطار هناك بعض الاستعدادات
لتشخيص الاضرار الموجوده هنا في هذه المدن
ايضا سنقدم الدعم للاسر المتضرره من هذه
الزلازل تم تحديد بعض
في متابعه لكلمه الرئيس التركي رجب
اردوغان اثناء تفقه لموقع مركز الزلازل في
ولايه قهرمان مرعش اردوغان كما تبعنا
مشاهدينا قال واجهنا مشاكل في الوصول
للمناطق المنكوبه والاستجابه للزلازل لكن
العمليات عادت لطبيعتها قال ايضا وتحدث عن
ارتفاع عدد القتلى الى ثمانيه الاف
وخمسمائه واربعه وسبعين قتيلا وقال سنساعد
الجميع ولا نترك مواطنا في الشارع وسنتصرف
سريعا بعد اردوغان ايضا وقال سننهي اعاده
اعمال المناطق المتضرره خلال عام واحد
وتحدث عن فتح الفنادق امام المتضررين في
مرسين وانطاليا
اذا كنا معكم اذا مشاهدينا كما ذكرنا في
متابعه لهذه الكلمه للرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان من موقع مركز الزلازل في ولايه
قهرمان مرعش هذه الصور الان نشاهدهم من
منطقه اضنه في تركيا حيث تجري عمليات
البحث عن ناجين بين انقاض الاف المباني
التي انهارت بسبب هذا الزلزال الذي ضرب
جنوب تركيا وشمال غرب سوريا صباح الاثنين
والذي بلغت قوته 7 درجات فاصله ثمانيه
فرقه لغات مشاهدينا كما اشرنا تحدثت عن
انهيار اكثر من 5000 مبنى في العديد من
المدن ما يفاق من سوء الاوضاع مشاهدينا هي
الهزه الارتداديه التي تعتبر امتدادا
للزلزال المدمر فقد ضربت هزه ارضيه بقوه
اربع درجات سواحل ولايه التركيه صباح هذا
اليوم هذا عدا عن اكثر من 680 هز ارتداديه
كان اعلن عنها وزير البيئه التركي اليوم
تعرضت لها تركيا حتى الان خلال
48 الماضيه اما نائب الرئيس التركي
مشاهدينا فقط اوضح يوم امس ان الظروف
الجويه القاسيه ايضا تجعل مهمه ايصال هذه
المساعدات للمناطق المنكوبه صعبه جدا لا
ننسى ايضا مشاهدينا سوريا التي ايضا تعاني
بشكل كبير وما اكثر من تركيا هناك ايضا
اللاجئون فلسطينيون ايضا الذين دخلوا على
خط هذه الازمه حيث افادت وكاله غوث وتشغيل
اللاجئين الفلسطينيين ان ثمانيه وخمسين
الف لاجئ فلسطيني تضرروا من هذا الزلزال
في المخيمات السوريه وان عدد القتلى
الفلسطينيين في سوريا وتركيا تجاوز
الستينات قتيلا هذا انزال المشاهدين ايضا
حرك مبدا التضامن الانساني وتحركت حكومات
والدول لتقديم هذه المساعدات العاجله من
دول منها السعوديه الولايات المتحده
وروسيا وفرنسا والمانيا وايطاليا
والامارات كذلك هذه التغطيه مستمره
مشاهدينا بعد قليل التقيكم الزميل خالد
مدخلي